IAN NI-LEWIS: Oh, did we forget
to have something?
DAN GALPIN: Hello, and welcome
to the Friday Games Review.
I'm your host, Dan Galpin, and
with me, once again, is Ian
Ni-Lewis, filling
in for Koh Kim.
IAN NI-LEWIS: That's right.
Koh's got very important work to
do, so she's leaving us to
drink beer and play
games without her.
DAN GALPIN: And speaking of
games, there are five on
today's list-- our crash-tastic
physics puzzler,
Spider Feeder.
IAN NI-LEWIS: That's right.
You have to click the button.
DAN GALPIN: Oh, yeah.
Deceptively simple Domino x4,
subliminally racist sorting
game, Metro Rush, unfortunately
named match
three game, Booty Quest,
and Space Ball.
IAN NI-LEWIS: And speaking of
beer, I think it's definitely
time to open some up.
Wow, that was great.
So we're experimenting with
having a scripted opening,
which for most of our
shows has worked
really, really well.
But this time, two issues--
first, I finished writing
the script at 3:02.
And second, Dan's sitting here
like a jerk holding the button
where I can't see it.
And I'm like, the slides
aren't even going.
What's going on?
DAN GALPIN: Exactly.
IAN NI-LEWIS: OK, now back up
because I have things to say.
Speaking of beer--
OK, so today's beer is Green
Flash Brewing Company's Double
Stout Black Ale.
DAN GALPIN: Excellent,
excellent.
By the way, I can't go back to
that slide because one of the
really cool things is if you
have slide auto go forward,
you can't ever go back to it
ever again with the clicker.
IAN NI-LEWIS: No way.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah, it totally
prevents you from doing it.
It sucks.
IAN NI-LEWIS: That's awesome.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah, exactly.
So I definitely need
this beer today.
IAN NI-LEWIS: We were going to
spend thousands of dollars on
teleprompting equipment.
But then we were like, why
not just use Keynote?
We've got a Mac.
DAN PHAM: Have either of you
guys noticed I'm wearing a
Green Flash Brewing shirt?
IAN NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
DAN GALPIN: Keynote needs a
little bit of work by its one
beta tester, I still think.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Nice.
Right.
Dan Pham, we were going to blame
beer on him, but he says
he didn't buy it.
So we actually don't
know who did.
DAN GALPIN: All right.
Stealing someone's beer.
DAN PHAM: I'm actually wearing a
Green Flash shirt, but I did
not bring that beer in.
Although, I will vouch for it
as a great double stout.
Good stuff.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Well, I definitely
liked their IPA,
which I think was called
Palate Wrecker.
DAN GALPIN: That's a great
name for an IPA.
IAN NI-LEWIS: So you'll
notice that we're
broadcasting today in space.
DAN GALPIN: Yes, exactly.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Let us know what
you think about this because
there have been haters.
I'll tell you, we put this black
background up because we
thought it looked kinda boss.
DAN GALPIN: Well, it looks
really, really good when you
guys have the lab
coats, actually.
And by the way, the reason I'm
wearing this hoodie is
partially just so I can contrast
a little bit more
against the black background.
IAN NI-LEWIS: You know, we put
up a massive, massive hair
light just to catch
the highlights off
your majestic do.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah, the highlights
off my skull.
That's always good.
DAN PHAM: We have a
comment already.
Obi-Wan Droid.
DAN GALPIN: Obi-Wan Droid.
Nice.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Nice.
Sweet.
All right, so we don't have a
producer today, but engineer
Dan's going to be watching the
comment stream because we're
too lazy to make him
do very much work.
In fact, today is the end
of the quarter for us.
We've been working on
performance reviews, which for
me means putting it off and Dan
Galpin means, once again,
writing a great review for me in
the attempt, yet again, to
get me promoted.
Because I am the Susan Lucci of
Android Developer Relations.
DAN GALPIN: It was mostly that
all of our reviews are due at
exactly 11:59 and 59
seconds last night.
And I was there until
11:59 and 59 seconds
still making comments.
And then I was filing
bugs after that.
So it's been a long night.
So it was a great time to go.
We were very excited about
getting to this crop of games
because I really needed some
distraction from all of this.
IAN NI-LEWIS: And
I'm hung over.
So let's go ahead and take
a look at our first game.
Oh, wait.
We can't.
DAN GALPIN: No, no the first
game is Booty Quest.
We can look at that.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Oh, OK.
Spider--
DAN GALPIN: Yeah, do
you see the order?
IAN NI-LEWIS: That's right.
Because in the script I just
put them in the order that
their names were funniest.
Let's go ahead and
take a look at--
I can't believe you put
Booty Quest first.
DAN GALPIN: Arr, well, you know
it was talk like a pirate
week last week.
And Booty Quest, it's a shame
you guys can't hear the audio
because the audio for
Booty Quest--
we can bring this up now--
the audio for Booty Quest is
actually kind of epic.
It really does have lots of
great pirate stuff in it.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Yo ho ho.
DAN GALPIN: And I love
their listing page.
This is actually a really,
really good way of doing a
listing page.
The text is a great size.
It's very, very readable.
You know immediately this
is going to be a
match four jewel game.
Yum.
It's got some great
characters in it.
Looking at the actual listing,
my only thing I would want
them to change would be the icon
because I see no reason
to have a giant rounded corner
thing when you've got this
really cool bird character
that you could
totally have pop.
And in fact out of the only
games, the only icon I really
liked out of all the games
was Space Ball.
We can continue to go
on this, though.
All right.
So let's get to the actual
Booty Quest.
Why does it say Metro Rush?
Wait, we'll stay
in Booty Quest.
Aha, better.
IAN NI-LEWIS: You
go to the next--
DAN GALPIN: Oh, I screwed
this up totally.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
DAN GALPIN: And one
other problem.
We have to actually plug
the tablet in.
IAN NI-LEWIS: We do?
DAN GALPIN: Yes, we do because
the tablet's not plugged in.
IAN NI-LEWIS: What,
but there's two--
DAN GALPIN: I know.
I know.
There's two inputs, but we're
not actually taking
advantage of that.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Seriously,
why did I spend all
the money on that?
DAN GALPIN: I know.
I know.
IAN NI-LEWIS: You guys suck.
DAN GALPIN: We do.
We totally do.
All right, let's plug this in
and let's actually get in to
Booty Quest.
Everyone's like, all right,
we're tuning out right now.
These guys are jokesters, man.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Actually, knowing
our audience, this is
probably when everybody's
going to tune in.
DAN GALPIN: Absolutely, they'll
be like, oh, this is
so cool, these guys.
All right, so a couple
of things to note
here on Booty Quest.
First of all, there's some
really nice effects.
The game has got actually
really great graphics.
And when we are playing it in
HDMI mode, we've got this
giant green line on the
right-hand side of the screen,
which is really kind of sad.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Are you serious?
That's not us?
DAN GALPIN: No, no.
That's actually the
game itself.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Nice.
DAN GALPIN: So everyone on
Android, you have to always
make sure that your game
really does need to do
something reasonable when you're
at 1.33 aspect ratio
all the way up to 1.77.
And also, you can't just look at
the size that's coming back
from the display because you
actually have to look at the
size of the screen that
you're given.
So this may actually
be that problem.
That's a really common thing to
go on with games, is people
will say hey, let's pull the
size of the display, let's
ignore the view that I'm
actually given, assume that
I'm asking for full screen, and
I'm just going to get the
whole thing.
You just cannot do that.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Right, because
you won't always get it.
DAN GALPIN: You can't do that.
You're not always going to get
the full screen, especially on
these tablets.
Although we did actually
make a change.
The original Honeycomb tablets
would actually give you the
full screen size.
And that screwed everybody up.
They're like, wait, wait.
So in order to make things
slightly easier, we do only
give you the window now that
you're going to render in.
But if you're plugged into HDMI,
you're still not going
to get all of that.
IAN NI-LEWIS: All right, so now
let's go over to engineer
Daniel who's waving his
arms frantically.
DAN GALPIN: Oh, is he?
He's like, no one can
hear you, Dan.
Your audio's completely
cutting off.
DAN PHAM: I'm actually just
interested in trying
some of that beer.
DAN GALPIN: Oh.
IAN NI-LEWIS: I see.
DAN GALPIN: It is really good.
And boy did I need it today.
IAN NI-LEWIS: It is
very good beer.
Yeah.
By the way, we're going to do a
short show today because two
of these games crash and
four of them suck.
So--
DAN GALPIN: That's not true.
I wouldn't go that far.
Actually, only one of them
crashes on both devices.
One of them actually only
runs on the phone.
We are going to switch to the
phone just to be nice and show
that one off.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Do you see why Dan
gets promoted and I don't?
Because he doesn't say things
like, your game sucks.
I love you, Dan.
DAN GALPIN: Mostly because I
write really great reviews.
DAN PHAM: I love
you guys, too.
IAN NI-LEWIS: It's
true, you know.
You're amazing.
DAN GALPIN: And I'm sorry
it says Metro Rush.
This really isn't Metro Rush.
This really is Booty Call.
The game is fun.
I mean, honestly I like
match four games.
IAN NI-LEWIS: It's more
of a match three game.
DAN GALPIN: Sorry, match
three games.
I don't know why I refer to
it as a match four game.
It's a jewel matching game.
It's really, really well done.
The animations and transitions
are smooth.
There's some special
things going on.
There's explosive gems.
The thing is, this category
is so full.
There are so many jewel matching
games on Android.
IAN NI-LEWIS: This is
a great example of a
jewel matching game.
But yeah, there are
a lot of them.
Well, you know what, let's
take it on its own terms.
The animation is great.
I love that it's got a little
bit of reactive physics.
When things get removed, it
feels like they're kind of
blowing up, and when they fall
down they're getting--
there's definitely some
math going on
here, and I love that.
It feels so professional.
DAN GALPIN: Absolutely.
The game is just really,
really fluid.
And it is really, actually,
fun to blow
things up with the gems.
So definitely my hat's
off in terms of game.
I would say, the only thing is
in terms of depth, there are
some super, super deep matching
games out there with
all sorts of different scenarios
that are really
complicated.
And there's even, like, one of
the ones we actually looked
here, which was Rise of
Atlantis, actually takes you
through this epic quest as you
go through, with all sorts of
different side things
going on.
So this is a really, really
full category.
But this game is very good.
I mean, I see no reason why it
wouldn't be a candidate for
being featured.
It does reasonable things in
terms of the handling of the
back key, but not everywhere.
Like, for example, not here.
But one of the things it does
not actually do is it does not
correctly target multiple
displays.
We still have the
compatibility zoom button available.
It's not targeting a new SDK
version, so we still have the
menu showing up.
And we're still having JNI
compatibility stuff thrown in.
So there's a couple of things
I like in the change.
I'd also like to make sure
that they're actually
correctly targeting
the screen.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Great stuff.
So let's go ahead and talk
about Metro Rush.
So yeah, Metro Rush.
I found it interesting.
At first, I couldn't actually
figure it out.
And then what I did figure it
out, I found it a little bit
disturbing.
DAN GALPIN: The fact that
you're sorting different
colored people into different
colored cars--
IAN NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah.
IAN NI-LEWIS: So here's regular
mode as opposed to, I
don't know, South Will
Rise Again mode.
So we get this train.
And you'll notice the train
has a very small
little green thing.
So now, yeah, we gotta
sort all of the green
people into the cars.
DAN GALPIN: And I think it's
supposed to represent the
route that they're going on.
But it just so happens that as
you're playing it, all the
green people look a lot alike.
Now we're orange.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Then the
orange people.
DAN GALPIN: And they all
have a different race.
I don't know why that's the--
IAN NI-LEWIS: Is that
guy orange?
DAN GALPIN: Oh, there we are.
We do have two.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Oh,
he was orange.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah.
But it is sort of interesting.
IAN NI-LEWIS: That's cool.
The orange guys are
Irish, I think.
DAN GALPIN: I think
you're right.
IAN NI-LEWIS: I guess so.
DAN GALPIN: Exactly.
So a couple things
about this game.
One is that, yeah, it definitely
needs an intro to
be like, what am I doing here.
It is kind of weird.
If you miss the train, they just
kind of stand on top of
the train, which I
kind of liked.
IAN NI-LEWIS: So it's
a little buggy.
And let's face it, this mechanic
has been done before,
it's been done better.
Witness--
I call up the--
DAN GALPIN: My favorite thing
is this at the bottom.
Like, the five guys that are
all like standing to hop on
each other at the bottom
of the screen.
But yes, it it is
a little buggy.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Yeah, you remember
that bathroom game
where they had first
men, women.
Then there was dogs.
Then there was androids and
you had to sort them?
DAN GALPIN: Yes.
IAN NI-LEWIS: That was
a good sorting game.
This game--
I mean, maybe if you're three.
DAN GALPIN: Well, and I'll say
some other things to note.
You can see that there is a
real, real problem with this
particular screen size
and resolution.
And you can see the retry button
and the quit button are
really squashed.
And this actually goes--
do we even have--
IAN NI-LEWIS: To be fair, this
system's an easy resolution.
It's not a common
aspect ratio.
DAN GALPIN: It's just the
resolution used by every
single Android tablet
out there.
IAN NI-LEWIS: No, no.
This isn't.
DAN GALPIN: Oh, yeah.
IAN NI-LEWIS: It's
in HDMI mode.
DAN GALPIN: Excuse me, yeah.
But even outside of HDMI mode,
it's still squashed.
IAN NI-LEWIS: So what I'm
saying, though, is that yeah,
the particular aspect ratio
that we're looking at is
extremely squashed because we're
in HDMI mode, and it's a
little bit weird.
DAN GALPIN: But let me point
one thing out there.
Sorry, go on.
So this is actually
their listing.
And the listing also has a
completely squashed and
different aspect ratio
from the actual game.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Well, but my point
really is that phones
are getting longer.
Aspect ratios change.
There is no device on the market
that I'm aware of that
will guarantee always being
the same forever.
With Android, the nice thing is
that at least we've thought
about that and gone through
the pain so that you can--
we have a new rule, right?
No static slides for more
than five seconds.
DAN GALPIN: So let's go back.
I just wanted to show that
because it was sort of
entertaining.
And I did want to actually
mention that this is also not
a particularly good
listing page.
But it is representative
of the game, at
least, which is good.
There's a lot of listings
that aren't.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Anyway, to be
fair, I guess what I was
trying to say is, Android gives
you the tools to deal
with these aspect
ratio changes.
And especially when you're doing
vector graphics, there
really shouldn't be any reason
to make these mistakes.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Now I've
said my piece.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah, that's good.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Dan, I'm
going to shut up now.
DAN PHAM: I have a really
important question from
someone on YouTube.
DAN GALPIN: Oh.
Important.
DAN PHAM: The question is, how
can you play with beer?
IAN NI-LEWIS: How can we
not play with beer?
Have you tried this game?
Don't do it in a dry county,
that's all I'm saying.
DAN GALPIN: All right, well,
I think that pretty
much says it all.
I mean, there's some
good ideas here.
It definitely needs to
feel more fluid.
My basic complaint with this
game, and I think part of it
is the aspect ratio, I think it
is having trouble dealing
with touches and with handling
the characters on this
particular screen.
IAN NI-LEWIS: And also, when
you're doing a sorting game
like this--
and I'll tell you what the main
problem is with the mechanics.
Let's talk about the things
they did right.
They did vector graphics.
And the vector graphics look
really, really good.
So those turned out well.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah.
I think they're high-res
Illustrator graphics that have
been rendered.
I don't think they're actually
vector here.
I think they've just been
rendered into bitmaps.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Quite possible.
The basic game idea, there's
nothing wrong with it.
I would say the interaction
is a little difficult.
A sorting game like this, you
probably want to have a little
bit of momentum physics so that
it doesn't turn into a
laborious dragging game where
you're fighting the interface
more than you're fighting
the game.
DAN GALPIN: And I was going to
say, on a phone it's not so
bad because you don't
have to drag as far.
But as soon as you get to a
tablet, if you don't actually
have the physics built into it,
then you really are just,
oh, I'm dragging this
thing across the
screen again and again.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Well, and you saw
many times Dan made this
same mistake.
You let go just a fraction
of a second too early.
And instead of getting in and
giving you points, you just
hit a bug, basically.
DAN GALPIN: It floats
to the top.
IAN NI-LEWIS: The guy just
sits on top of the train
looking weird.
It's really great when the train
then takes off and runs
them all over, by the way,
which it does do.
But there's no running
over [INAUDIBLE].
IAN NI-LEWIS: I guess, yeah.
It's kind of fun.
Anyway, this is some great
programming, no
question about it.
It's just, it's not finished.
It's not a finished game.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah, it
needs more work.
IAN NI-LEWIS: All right.
Let's move on.
DAN GALPIN: All right.
So our next title in all of
this, let's go back--
this was the fun one for us.
This a game that we actually
were unable to get to run on
any of our devices.
IAN NI-LEWIS: I can't even tell
you how much I wanted to
play this game.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah,
we were excited.
Well, actually, looking at
the listing, we weren't
particularly excited.
IAN NI-LEWIS: No, I
was really stoked.
I watched their video.
It looked good.
DAN GALPIN: Oh, OK.
OK, looking at the listing,
I wasn't sure.
You can see that if you had this
on a device, you would
never be able to
read the text.
And I can't read it from here.
Well, I can read the
title barely.
IAN NI-LEWIS: And part of the
problem too is that they
haven't differentiated the
title and the tagline.
If you look at, let's say, a
movie poster, the title is
big, the tagline is small.
It's a good tagline
as taglines go.
DAN GALPIN: The spider
is hungry.
IAN NI-LEWIS: You
have to feed it.
DAN GALPIN: You have
to feed it.
IAN NI-LEWIS: OK.
But instead, it's like Spider
Feeder, the spider hungry, you
have to feed it.
It doesn't look like a listing,
it looks like a meme.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah.
So this game failed to load
because it couldn't actually
get a class that it needed,
which caused its main
class to not load.
So all we're going to have
is a green screen.
I will show you what happened.
I will launch it here.
And you'll get, unfortunately
Spider Feeder has stopped,
which is very sad.
IAN NI-LEWIS: So what
class was it?
DAN GALPIN: Unfortunately, when
you have a class that is
from the main activity class, it
prevents the main activity
class from loading, but you
can't see what it is.
Because you just see, oh,
the main activity
class failed to load.
Because one of the things it's
depending on wasn't there.
IAN NI-LEWIS: You should be
able to see, there's the
really long listing and you
get down to the bottom.
DAN GALPIN: It depends
on where it crashes,
unfortunately.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Did
you strace it?
DAN GALPIN: I did
not strace it.
I just used logcat on it.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Yeah, you probably
wouldn't have gotten
much out of it.
DAN GALPIN: With strace,
unfortunately, this is all
deck stuff.
So strace would just
let me know it was
trying to load a file.
strace is really cool, though.
If you're trying to debug native
stuff, it's actually
really, really useful to know
which call your app made that
caused things to crash.
So definitely thumbs
up on strace.
We actually made a nice
update to that tool in
the last six months.
So if you haven't used
it recently--
IAN NI-LEWIS: This is awesome.
Check that out.
DAN GALPIN: Oh, yeah.
We're very close to being able
to install Jelly Bean on our
little Transformer Prime here,
which is very exciting.
And I'm hoping it'll work
because that'll be fun.
But I didn't want to do it right
before this show just in
case something went wrong.
IAN NI-LEWIS: How could
that happen?
That would be really
surprising.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah,
it'd shocking.
So the next app we're going to
actually look at is Domino x4.
And this game is a really
beautifully done--
IAN NI-LEWIS: Was I right?
Is this a deceptively
simple game?
DAN GALPIN: It is.
IAN NI-LEWIS: I hadn't
even played the game.
I was writing the script.
I'm like, oh, dominoes.
I bet it's deceptively simple.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah, this is
actually really fun.
It's a puzzle game.
It's a time-based game.
Here's what the listing
looks like, which is
actually pretty good.
It's pretty representative
of the game.
You see, we actually
get some nice.
Because it's got green on it,
we're getting some green
screen showing through with our
little presentation here.
Yeah, you can see
us behind there.
And I would still like the text
to be slightly larger.
And just that font, I've never
liked for this kind of thing.
But it's fun.
But it's everyone's taste.
However, we actually get to
the game itself, and I'll
launched it here
on the tablet.
And you'll see why this game
we're actually going to switch
to the phone.
First of all, menu looks fine.
Not exciting.
The text, you can see,
is kind of small.
That's because we're ending
up [INAUDIBLE]
domino.
And that's because we're
on an MDPI device.
And these things just look
huge on an MDPI device.
When you're actually looking at
how do I make my app scale
for the tablets, sometimes it
makes sense to actually select
a different resource type.
And you can actually do that.
So that's one thought here.
And we actually go
to new game.
And you can see--
IAN NI-LEWIS: Wow.
It is deceptively simple.
DAN GALPIN: It's just
not playable.
IAN NI-LEWIS: No,
this is awesome.
Oh my god.
Best game or best game ever?
How do I play it?
What do we do?
DAN GALPIN: You rotate
the dominoes.
And as you can see,
unfortunately--
IAN NI-LEWIS: It's like
a Nyquist game.
Oh yeah, this domino doesn't
just affect itself.
It affects dots in other
dominoes as well.
DAN GALPIN: So unfortunately,
what we're seeing here is that
the matrix that's being used
to scale the bitmap is just
not correct for this screen
size and resolution.
And so we're just
seeing the dots.
They're actually all overlapping
each other.
And the game is not playable.
But because we are trying to
make sure that you guys can
actually see how the game is
played, we're now going to
switch from the tablet view--
you'll see us lose this
momentarily--
to our trusty Galaxy Nexus.
All right.
Yes.
IAN NI-LEWIS: I love how we
have this great on-screen
animation and everything looks
really smooth, but it's the
result of you picking up a
cord off the floor and
plugging it into
something else.
DAN GALPIN: I know.
IAN NI-LEWIS: We're so
low tech/high tech.
DAN GALPIN: I know.
And Daniel's hard work.
So here is Domino.
And here's what it looks like.
Now, there are some rendering
problems,
even on Galaxy Nexus.
You can see that it's cut off.
I'm not sure why this is
actually the case because it
doesn't actually happen--
IAN NI-LEWIS: At this point,
I don't even know what I'm
looking at.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah.
So what's actually going on here
is you're seeing a couple
of rendering problems.
It's worse with HDMI because
you're getting a slightly
different screen size
there as well.
If you actually get it full
screen, it's less cut off.
But as you can see, at
least we can see the
game to play it.
So we can rotate the dominoes
so that they line up.
And the goal is to get
bricks of dominoes
that line up together--
this is actually really hard
to play with HDMI because I
can't see how many dots are
actually on each domino.
IAN NI-LEWIS: So what do you
think they're doing there?
DAN GALPIN: I'm not
sure, honestly.
I'd have to look at
their layout.
If I had a little more time, I
would have actually tried to
pull apart their layout and
see why it's wrong.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Don't
lean against that.
God, how many times do
I have to tell you?
DAN GALPIN: It's so
soft, though.
We've got a soft velvet
background.
This thing looks
black, but it's
actually black and squishy.
IAN NI-LEWIS: As soon as I get
my glow in the dark paints,
Elvis, baby.
DAN GALPIN: Nice.
Yeah, actually, I'd
like black light.
That'd be kind of cool to do
a black light episode.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Oh, that
would be rocking.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah.
We should totally do that.
IAN NI-LEWIS: We should do a
Halloween episode since we're
about to be swamped
with zombie games.
DAN GALPIN: That it's true.
IAN NI-LEWIS: What made
zombies a thing?
Why are zombies such a
big deal these days?
DAN GALPIN: I think it was the
zombie head that PopCap
created for Plants vs.
Zombies, I really do.
IAN NI-LEWIS: I guess.
I don't know.
DAN GALPIN: They spent, like,
$3,000 making this zombie
head, and it becomes
this viral video.
It's like that and "Gangnam
Style." That's what we're
going to see at Halloween.
DAN PHAM: So it's safe to assume
that neither of you
guys have a zombie kit prepared
at home, right?
DAN GALPIN: I do, actually.
I have a zombie kit at home.
In case of zombie invasion,
I'm totally set.
Except I don't have a shotgun.
IAN NI-LEWIS: He didn't make
it for zombies, though.
He made it for Communists.
DAN GALPIN: No, no.
Earthquakes, actually.
But it's earthquake/zombie
invasion.
IAN NI-LEWIS: My parents
had a Communist kit.
DAN GALPIN: Did they really?
IAN NI-LEWIS: Yeah, as soon
as the invasion came--
DAN GALPIN: The Commie
invasion!
All right, so let's switch
back to the tablet.
I just wanted to show that.
Actually, without HDMI, it was
much, much more playable.
So I'm sad you guys can't see
the game because it's actually
really, really fun.
You're actually matching
different tetrominoes together
with the dominoes.
And so it's actually a very,
very clever game.
IAN NI-LEWIS: That's
the Lemmings font.
I wondered where I'd
seen that before.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah, it's totally
the Lemmings font.
I'm trying to remember
the name of it.
I think it's Cooper.
No, Cooper is the other plate.
It'll come to me.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Copperplate?
DAN GALPIN: It's not
Copperplate.
No, it is.
It's Cooper Black.
That's right.
It's not Copperplate.
It's Cooper Black.
That's what it is.
Yes.
Ha, ha.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Doesn't that
totally sound like a whiskey
or something?
DAN GALPIN: It should
be, yeah.
It would be great to make a
Cooper Black whiskey that
actually had the font
on the front.
All right, so we're
going to go to our
final game, which is--
IAN NI-LEWIS: Space Ball.
DAN GALPIN: Space Ball.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Which unlike the
rest of these, we had no idea
how to make a joke
out of this name.
DAN GALPIN: We're playing
with balls, man.
Come on.
All right.
This one actually is our
only landscape game.
Yeah, Mr. Pham.
All right.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Rock on!
DAN GALPIN: High five to
our engineer, man.
He's been kicking some
serious booty.
IAN NI-LEWIS: We've got some
real problems here.
We've got a much more
professional set up, and yet
we're not professional at all.
Hey, what happened to
the producer cam?
DAN GALPIN: Yeah, where's
IAN NI-LEWIS: Dude, you
put it over there.
DAN PHAM: Actually, I
disconnected it so we could
have both tablet and
phone available.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah.
So we have all of these cameras,
but we don't have a
power strip that actually has
a socket for it so we could
plug both in at the same time.
DAN PHAM: Yeah, I don't think
the fire marshal would be too
happy with our electronic
set up.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Dude,
don't say that.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Look, there's a
power strip on the floor over
there that's got nothing
plugged into it at all.
DAN GALPIN: That is
actually true.
There's several in this room.
It's completely safe.
IAN NI-LEWIS: And he has a power
strip over there that
could probably handle
a nuclear reactor.
DAN GALPIN: That thing
is amazing.
That is seriously kick butt.
It's meant to power soldering
irons and heat guns, and we
have it here for powering
laptops and phones.
All right, so Space Ball.
First of all, I want to say--
IAN NI-LEWIS: First of all,
it's not Spaceballs.
It's Space Ball.
DAN GALPIN: It's Space Ball.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Right.
It's not a licensed property.
DAN GALPIN: Yes.
Just in case you were curious,
even though it looks exactly,
and the font seems like, and
actually it feels very
cartoony, very much like the
movie, this has nothing to do
with the movie, unless
I'm totally mistaken.
DAN GALPIN: Dude, I don't think
you're thinking about
Spaceballs.
I think you're thinking
about NBA Jam.
IAN NI-LEWIS: So there's a
serious problem here, though.
I mean, look at this.
Now actually, our new studio
set up is really useful for
this because we are actually
about 10 to 12 feet away from
a very, very small monitor
showing this.
And in terms of arc radians,
it's about the same size as
what it would be on a phone
held at arm's length.
I cannot make heads or
tails out of this.
DAN GALPIN: It looks
like [GIBBERISH]
next to the character.
And the thing is, it would be
fine at that size if there was
more contrast.
But right now, with the amount
of contrast there is between
the Space Ball logo and the
back, it's actually very, very
difficult to read.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Remember, the
weirder your font, the lower
your contrast, the bigger
it needs to be
in order to be legible.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah.
And it's such a great logo, I
would really like to see that.
I'd like to see just a little
bit more contrast between the
text and the background.
Other than that, this icon, by
the way, wins the icon award
of the week.
As I said earlier, this
is what an Android
icon should look like.
Other game developers,
take note.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Right?
DAN GALPIN: Seriously.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Now move
on so I can see your
beautiful face there.
DAN GALPIN: Other game
developers take note.
There we are.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Otherwise he's
going to mess you up.
Look at him.
He's from the hood.
That's why he's got a hoodie.
DAN GALPIN: Absolutely,
with an antenna on it.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Oh, dude-- can
we both do it like this?
DAN GALPIN: Yeah!
Actually, it kind of
fits for this game.
So this game's got a little--
IAN NI-LEWIS: OK, I'm
that dude from
Assassin's Creed now.
DAN GALPIN: Oh, you
totally are, man.
You're from the future.
IAN NI-LEWIS: [INAUDIBLE].
DAN GALPIN: And this
isn't even your
Assassin's Creed hoodie.
IAN NI-LEWIS: No, it's not.
I do have an Assassin's Creed
hoodie, but it's not nearly as
good for playing Assassin's
Creed.
DAN GALPIN: Exactly.
IAN NI-LEWIS: OK, Space Ball.
DAN GALPIN: So Space Ball
is a shooting game.
And it's actually kind of a
shooting gallery basketball
game, which I thought
was really cool.
IAN NI-LEWIS: You sound
so disappointed.
It's a shooting game.
DAN GALPIN: It's a basketball
shooting game.
But it's well done.
And it's actually really
different.
I like the little animations.
There's not a lot of crazy
animation, but they're there.
Your goal is to line up the
shot into the baskets.
IAN NI-LEWIS: You've got
to be kidding me.
Oh my god.
DAN GALPIN: And you get points
for getting runs.
You don't want to get them into
those things because you
lose your ball.
And now I'm screwed because
I lost my ball.
IAN NI-LEWIS: What kind of
highly advanced culture is
responsible for this madness?
DAN GALPIN: I totally
screwed that up.
So then you have to
drop the ball.
And now I've dropped it far away
from him, so I'm screwed.
As far as I know, I
can't get it back.
IAN NI-LEWIS: What?
DAN GALPIN: Yeah, I
can't get it back.
IAN NI-LEWIS: What, dude can't
walk over and just get it?
DAN GALPIN: I don't think so.
Maybe you can.
I never figured that out.
IAN NI-LEWIS: How lazy are
you, little purple dude?
DAN GALPIN: I know.
Well, I was trying to
figure that out.
Maybe if you tilt--
Oh, you tilt him.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Oh!
Look at that.
DAN GALPIN: Ah, OK.
There we are.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Once again,
totally flummoxed by an
accelerometer.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah, I know.
I know.
Not to mention, we
lost the HDMI.
By the way, I've decided I hate
micro-HDMI with a passion.
I hope we never put
it in products.
IAN NI-LEWIS: You realize that
consumer connectors are not
meant for this stuff.
DAN GALPIN: I know.
I know.
OK, makes the game
way more fun.
I'm sitting here, playing with
this on the desk, being like,
this game seems really
not very dynamic.
IAN NI-LEWIS: So that's
something--
I'm not going to say that you're
typical, but still,
it's always nice to add a little
bit of discoverability.
DAN GALPIN: Ah!
Die, die, stuck ball.
Oh, that was cool.
The stuck ball gave
me a basket.
So anyways, I actually think
the game's really fun.
I would like the accelerometer
mechanic to be a little bit
easier found.
And I actually don't think
this game needs an
accelerometer.
Games that have accelerometer
where they don't really need
one drive me nuts, as
a general rule.
Now maybe there is a way
to change the controls.
Maybe I can go back, and
there's a way to say--
IAN NI-LEWIS: That's possible.
I mean, I think you can make the
argument that you need one
hand for shooting and you're
going to be better-- but the
problem is too--
actually, no.
I'm going to rant
for a second.
Here's the problem.
When you're doing accelerometer
stuff, that
takes a hand.
It takes at least one
hand, and it feels
better with two hands.
Now, at the same time, let's say
that you need to touch the
screen in a specific place.
Impossible.
You know why?
Because you're tilting the
device all over the place.
Do you see how hard I'm trying
not to say the F-word now?
DAN GALPIN: Well, on a tablet,
this game kind of sucks
because of that.
IAN NI-LEWIS: It's one thing
when you have a mechanic where
there's a couple buttons on the
side of the screen that
you can get with your
thumb while
you're twisting it around.
But if you have to move your
device and do any kind of
precision touching, that's going
to be frustrating for
most of your users, no matter
what kind of device they have.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah.
And the other thing is, in
general, accelerometer games
on tablets have to
be really, really
carefully thought through.
So that would be my only
comment, is if you're going to
do one, first of all, it's
better to have multiple
control options anyways.
We've already shown that if you
give people the options to
have different controllers,
they'll love you.
If you don't--
oh, man.
I totally want to get
that 3x score.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Or even just
simplify your control.
I mean, do you really have to
control the way this guy runs?
It's pretty obvious where
he's going to run to.
Maybe you should think
about making the
mechanic a little simpler.
DAN GALPIN: Making a
mode where he just
goes and grabs it.
Although it is a nice--
ooh, TNT.
Yeah.
Oh.
That was bad.
But I love the different
game modes in the game.
The game is totally cool
in the way it plays.
I actually would like to see
it not use an accelerometer
because it's just kinda dinky.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Yeah, it's really
just the control screen.
The graphics are nice, the
animation's nice, it's got a
fun mechanic, it's not super
deep, but it's interesting.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah I want to
see higher-res graphics,
admittedly.
IAN NI-LEWIS: This is the kind
of game I can imagine taking
to the bar and just making some
bets over and just trash
talking with my friends, oh man,
I bet you can't make this
many baskets, or whatever.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah.
No, it's totally cool.
I would love to see kind of a
social-- there is social stuff
built into the game.
But I'm sure it can
be taken further.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Actually, I don't
need social stuff built
into the game because
I have friends.
And we just have--
I'm lying.
I don't have any friends.
DAN GALPIN: I was going
to say, come on, man.
So it does have GREE
built into it.
I don't actually know if it
enables any social modes
because when I see these
things, I'm like,
I don't like fun.
So anyways, Space Ball, I
definitely would like to see
some higher-res graphics.
It does look really blocky
on a tablet.
And on a phone, it's OK.
But otherwise, the game
does really well.
It actually, for the most
part, yields to our
guidelines.
Except here, where hitting the
back doesn't do anything.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Yields
to our guidelines?
That is the best way
I've heard--
it submits to our guidelines.
It becomes our supplicant.
DAN GALPIN: It does!
Meaning that as an Android user,
you're mostly not going
to be annoyed with it.
Now, this is totally annoying.
Come on, GREE.
Make the back key actually do
something useful in your app.
Seriously, look at this.
The only time I've seen
the game crash--
right inside of GREE's stuff.
What is up with that?
IAN NI-LEWIS: That's a
perennial problem.
And let's just remind everyone
that although middleware gets
things wrong all the time,
it's your problem.
If you put middleware in your
game and it screws something
up, and you don't get featured
because of that, don't write
to us and say, oh, but
it's my middleware.
Can't I get a free pass?
No, you can't.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah, middleware
is the one that's grabbing
everyone's phone numbers and
saving them in an evil
database so that overlords
can contact you by SMS.
No, man.
It's still your fault.
That's like, I'm sorry.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Exactly.
And the truth is, our hands
are kind of tied.
We can't take your
middleware out.
That's your decision, to take
it out or put it in.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah.
Sorry.
I was hit with a "Gangnam
Style" vibe.
It's been a long week.
IAN NI-LEWIS: And if you choose
to put in middleware
that doesn't work or does
something wrong, that's just
as bad as programming a
bug into your game.
All right, so let's go
ahead and take a
look at our live stream.
Engineer Dan, what are the
people saying out there?
DAN PHAM: We've got a bunch
of different comments.
But we do have a question
from Owen.
So Owen's asking, can you guys
try to explain how to scale
some of the art using matrices
for different screen
resolutions?
DAN GALPIN: So there's a couple
of ways of doing it.
If you're a view-based game--
IAN NI-LEWIS: Using canvas?
DAN GALPIN: No, if you're a
view-based game, like one in
which you are actually using
custom views, you can use
image view, you can use a matrix
associated with that.
Actually, it's kind of nice.
We give you a matrix that
actually has multiple
different kinds of
transformations.
And we actually give you a bunch
of functions to allow
you to create the matrix without
understanding the
matrix math, which
is kind of cool.
IAN NI-LEWIS: It's
a 3 by 3 matrix.
And if you don't understand the
matrix math, you'll never
be able to debug it.
DAN GALPIN: Yes, that's true.
IAN NI-LEWIS: And the functions
don't always work
the way you think they should.
And the moral of the story
is, learn math.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah.
And actually, Ian has a really,
really great code
sample that he did, which is
part of Android U, which is
his custom view code sample,
which actually goes through
using matrix math to do a bunch
of transformations,
including rotation
and scaling.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Yeah, that's
somewhat true.
I had to cut it down a lot
because people said, oh, maybe
it's a little too hard.
DAN GALPIN: Maybe you
shouldn't expect
people to know math.
That might have helped.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Ian had a
much better example
that used more math.
IAN NI-LEWIS: But the important
thing is, remember
that a 3 by 3 matrix
encapsulates pretty much any
mapping between the
2 by 2 spaces.
So for an XY coordinate system,
in a 3 by 3 matrix,
you can do translation,
rotation, scaling, skewing,
perspectives, et cetera.
And building that matrix is
something that our functions
will do for you.
But concatenating multiple
matrices together--
also something that we'll do,
but you need to understand how
the math works in order to make
sure that you're doing it
in the right order.
Matrix multiplication, unlike
most other types of
multiplication, is
non-communicative, which can
really trip people up.
Witness the incorrect math
that was actually--
DAN GALPIN: In our
OpenGL sample.
IAN NI-LEWIS: --shipped in our
OpenGL sample, which was a
tricky one because there was not
only bad math, but there
was a memory overwrite that we
didn't catch, which made it
look like it was good math
for certain conditions.
DAN GALPIN: It actually looked
like it was doing something
reasonable, which is
always dangerous.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Best stack
overflow question ever.
And I have to say, by
the way, Joe and
I both wrote responses.
And his was like, oh
yeah, it's wrong.
I'll fix it.
And mine is like, well,
here's how it's wrong.
Here's the fix, blah,
blah, blah.
But he mentioned that he was the
guy that wrote the sample,
so his got accepted.
DAN GALPIN: No way.
IAN NI-LEWIS: I'm still bitter
about that because my stack
overflow reputation isn't
exactly the best in the world.
You could always
go vote it up.
DAN GALPIN: Exactly.
He's the man.
Come on.
He fixed the math.
IAN NI-LEWIS: The main thing is
that, yeah, you're applying
a scale matrix to your bitmaps
in order to fit them into a
specific place.
But it seemed like either the
scaling was wrong or it was
being applied in the wrong
order because as you're
rotating things, they were being
scaled way out beyond
the bounds of where we thought
they should be.
I don't know if that helps
answer your question.
If not, then sign on to Office
Hours on Wednesday.
You can ask up live.
DAN GALPIN: And one more thing
I'd like to add is that it's
really important, since the
matrix can do all those
transformations, use the
matrix for all of them.
Don't try to say, well, I'm
going to put this thing in a
surface view, and then I'm going
to try to set a scale
factor somewhere else.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Yeah, [INAUDIBLE]
is important.
DAN GALPIN: Rely on the matrix
to do everything.
One, it's really fast.
And two, it actually will make
your code a lot simpler.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Well, you've
got to remember, too,
what's going on here.
DAN GALPIN: I'm telling people
to rely on the matrix.
I feel like I'm in a movie
or something like that.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Dude,
you're so old.
DAN GALPIN: I know.
IAN NI-LEWIS: So the thing is,
remember that obviously for
software rendering, this
doesn't matter.
But for hardware rendering,
anything that's done using the
matrix will be done
by the GPU.
I'm sure there are some
exceptions to that.
But that's a general rule.
Whereas if you do something
without using the matrix, it's
a bit of a crap shoot.
You don't know if you're
going to get it or not.
Now, there are some things you
need to be careful of.
For instance, let's say that you
draw a path and then scale
it using the matrix.
That will be very fast, but
the quality will be low
because GPUs aren't very good
at drawing paths, so we draw
the path in software and then
scale it up or scale it down.
Which means one of my favorite
things to do in the old
system, which was to always draw
paths in a 1 by 1 box and
then scale it to whatever--
no.
DAN GALPIN: Bad.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Don't do that.
That would be a sad thing.
But for things that are
already drawn--
bit maps, text, especially--
things that can be scaled and
rotated by the hardware, make
sure that you do that.
Of course, it's a little bit
more complicated than just
using the canvas matrices.
You also have to make sure
that you're in a layer.
And my class on doing
custom controls,
developer.android.com/training,
I think.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah, that
sounds right.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Anyway, I have
a class on doing custom
controls, and it explains how
to draw something to a layer
so that you can very quickly
rotate it and get
buttery-smooth graphics, even
though the operation that
you're doing is kind
of expensive.
DAN GALPIN: And the other guys
you should look at as class
actually are the guys who
did the Metro Rush game.
Because his custom control
actually talks about physics,
and he actually has some
very, very nice
fling physics in that.
And I think that would help
the game out immensely.
And you can actually use the
built-in physics model you get
with our gesture detector
to do a lot of that.
IAN NI-LEWIS: And the other
people who should look at my
class is everybody.
Because I need the page views.
Come on.
DAN GALPIN: It's true.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Daddy needs a new
Tesla Model S. All right.
DAN GALPIN: We need to
get him promoted.
It's very important.
IAN NI-LEWIS: All right, so--
DAN GALPIN: Anything else
in the live stream?
DAN PHAM: Yeah.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Pham's like, hey,
there's some comments.
Oh, and here's something I'm
actually going to read too.
DAN GALPIN: Here's what we can
actually read on the air.
DAN PHAM: I'm not exactly sure
if you guys answered Owen's
question yet, but he posted a
little bit of an explanation.
IAN NI-LEWIS: We answered
it poorly.
DAN PHAM: Yeah.
DAN GALPIN: I blame the stout.
DAN PHAM: So specifically,
he says--
IAN NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
We don't know exactly what they
did wrong in the domino
game is the problem.
Anyway--
DAN PHAM: So he's saying, say
you design your vector art in
480 by 800 res.
Now you want to have support
for a large screen, HDPI
phone, say 1,200 by 600
resolution, he's looking for
technical details on
how to scale that.
I'm not sure if you guys
addressed that in your
explanation.
DAN GALPIN: OK, so there's
two different things.
If you're vector art, you're
importing it as a bitmap--
IAN NI-LEWIS: Yeah, that's one
really important thing.
Are you doing it as vector,
or are you--
DAN GALPIN: No, he
said bitmap.
IAN NI-LEWIS: So he's going
to author that.
Yeah
DAN GALPIN: So in general--
yeah, so in general, if you can
actually display vector
art in your game, then what
we generally recommend is
exporting a relatively high
quality version of it and
putting it in a higher density
to start with.
That helps the phones like the
Galaxy Nexus that are hxdpi
because you'll end up getting
high-resolution artwork on there.
Now, the bigger question
is how do I do the
same thing on a tablet?
There's a couple of different
ways of doing that.
One way you can do things--
and this is fairly
straightforward--
you can actually throw the
artwork into a nodpi folder
and you can just try
to select a scale
factor that makes sense.
Don't rely on the system
to scale it at all.
Then you run into one other
problem on the very low-end
devices with memory.
Because you're going to be
loading in, potentially, a
much larger set of bitmaps than
it's designed to take,
which is part of the reason why
we do all the DPI-based
loading that we do.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Right.
You want to try and load
whatever is as close to your
DPI as possible.
And the system's going
to take care of that.
So let me try and break down
what we were talking about
matrices because Dan says matrix
any time he wants to
sound smart.
So here's what we're
going to do.
All you're going to do
is scale this stuff.
But the important thing is
there's really two ways to
scale a bitmap in Android.
You can use a draw bitmap and
give it a destination rect
that's different from your
source rect, and
that will do scaling.
Or you can draw it to a canvas
at its original rectangle and
apply a scale matrix to
the entire canvas.
And the problem comes when you
mix them, so when you mix the
two techniques.
Well no, because applying the
scale matrix to the canvas is
applying it to each
drawing operating.
It's not a full scale.
So what we were suggesting is
that you pick the canvas size
that you feel is native, so
whatever you had in mind.
Now remember, this isn't going
to take care of aspect ratio,
it's going to take
care of size.
Now, for aspect ratio,
you need to
make some other decisions.
You may want to do a little
bit of [INAUDIBLE]
move some of your UI elements
out further or
something like that.
And the other thing that's a
little tricky is on a tablet--
so normally what Android does is
if you have, let's say, an
xhdpi resource, and you try to
load it onto a tablet, which
is an MDPI device, Android's
automatically going to go
[SQUISH], and it's going
to squish that down.
And it's going to make an MDPI
size because its goal is it's
trying through to retain the
physical size of that bitmap,
which for a lot of actual
non-game UI is very nice.
Because what you really want
a tablet, often, is just to
display more information.
However, there's a balance.
So what you can do is
a couple of things.
One is you can actually say,
when I'm on an extra-large
device, let's not use the DPI
that is built into it.
You can actually say, I'm on an
extra-large screen device,
I'm going to make use of higher
resolution assets.
And you can actually set that
and tell the resource loader
actually, go load me
the next level up.
The other thing you can do is,
if you're going to do that a
lot, you can simply store your
resources in a no-DPI folder
and then do some calculations
yourself to
determine how to scale.
Because actually, if you look
at what's going on inside of
the resource loader, all it's
doing is it's telling the
bitmap factory to scale.
Now, one thing that's kind of
nice that you can also do-- if
you want to do it a little
bit more optimally--
is that there's actually two
ways in which, on loading, you
can scale bitmaps.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Well, but the
thing is, I think when we were
talking about the dominoes--
and this is why I was going
with the matrix direction--
I feel like we're sort of
diverging into two different
stories here.
But the problem was not that--
I mean, I'm sure he was loading
the wrong resource,
but it felt like the real
problem was he was drawing the
dominoes with one set of scale
factors and he was using--
DAN GALPIN: Yes, drawing
the dots with another
set of scale factors.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Exactly.
DAN GALPIN: And the other thing
is that the dominoes are
very, very--
IAN NI-LEWIS: So we've got the
DPI thing, we've got the
matrix thing-- let's
separate those and
finish one or the other.
So you talk about
the DPI thing.
DAN GALPIN: So for DPI, you've
got two problems that are
fighting each other.
You want to make sure that you
make video memory still work
on devices that have limited
video memory.
So where it makes sense to
do what is going with the
standard transformations, it
does make sense to use them or
to simply apply similar
ones yourself.
The second thing is that you
really want to make sure that
on a tablet, if you want to
display things bigger, that
you do select larger
resolution assets.
And the easiest thing to do is
simply to enumerate the kind
of assets you have and
select the right one.
That's what a lot of
game developers do.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Now, if you do the
DPI thing too, if you're
in the DPI folders, you can
basically work in DIPs, right?
You don't have to work
in actual pixels?
DAN GALPIN: That's correct.
Your can do all of your
layouts in DIPs.
The only problem with that is
obviously this thing has a
much larger amount of DIPs.
And so you're going to
actually want to have
different resources.
People don't want to have
HDPI-slash-extra large resources.
That's actually the correct way
of having different scaled
resources, is to actually have
separate bitmaps that are for
tablets for HDPI and for
phones for HDPI.
And that just gets
kind of messy.
So in this case, in order to
keep the image really small,
in order to keep things
relatively simple, you'll
probably want to do a little bit
of math just to make sure
you get the right size images
with the highest quality
available for these
MDBI tablets.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Right.
So let's move on
to that, then.
Especially if you're
thinking in DIPs.
So DIPs are supposed to be
related to physical units.
DAN GALPIN: And they
are, actually.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Right.
Well--
yes.
DAN GALPIN: They're related.
They're not exactly related.
IAN NI-LEWIS: So the trick here
is that a 4-inch phone
and a 10-inch tablet may
actually have the same number
of pixels but a different
number of DIPs.
So I think what we're suggesting
is that you might
want to go ahead and decide on
a native dimensions in DIPs
and then either expand
or contract by
setting a scale factor.
Now, how do you set
that scale factor?
Well, you do it in the matrix
of your canvas.
And you make sure that for all
of the elements that are
supposed to be occupying the
same physical space in your
game board, that matrix
needs to be the same.
And the domino game is probably
using one matrix for
drawing the triangles and
using another matrix for
drawing the dots.
And that's where they're
running into problems.
DAN GALPIN: I think so.
I think that's exactly
what's going on.
I think actually, it's probably
drawing the triangles
as based just purely on what's
coming on the screen.
And it's probably loading the
bitmap images and making
assumptions about the size
of them and then
trying to scale those.
That's my guess.
We even saw on Galaxy Nexus with
that game that even going
to HDMI and plugging that in
made the game unplayable.
So there's probably some
calculations going on that are
based on the display size rather
than on the viewport
size it's given as well.
So there's probably a number
of different issues.
You have to really make sure
that when the system tells you
no, rescale your viewport, you
really have to go and redo
those calculations.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Yeah, and that's
very important as well.
So you have to remember that
you're going to be on a
multitude of different
devices.
And this is actually where 3D
games have a real advantage
because 3D games are used to
having to do viewport mapping,
mapping from your 3D world, into
what we call clip space.
But 2D games, a lot of times,
haven't had to deal with that
unless you're coming from a
background of games that were
actually written to be resized
on, let's say, a desktop PC.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah.
And there's no reason why a game
like dominoes shouldn't
be resizable and scalable.
And there's a lot of ways
to attack that.
So I think maybe that
helps a little bit.
IAN NI-LEWIS: And if not,
drop something on
Stack Overflow, and--
DAN GALPIN: Ian'll get
some more points.
IAN NI-LEWIS: --ping
us through G+.
And yeah, totally, we'll
do the work.
DAN GALPIN: Ian needs
some more reps.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Oh, yeah.
DAN GALPIN: So he'll be there.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Big time.
DAN GALPIN: And so
do I, actually.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Anything
else on the internet?
DAN PHAM: Yeah, so this
is the last question.
One of our users wants to know
if we have any guidelines on
dealing with performance
variety between devices
because the filtering only
handles GPU and screen size.
IAN NI-LEWIS: That's is
the billion-dollar
question, isn't it?
DAN GALPIN: So yeah, actually,
it doesn't really handle GPU.
It handles OpenGL ES version.
And it doesn't really--
IAN NI-LEWIS: It handles
texture format.
DAN GALPIN: It handles
IAN NI-LEWIS: Which is a sort
of proxy for GPU but not a
very good one.
DAN GALPIN: So today, there's
two low-hanging fruit
that you can use.
One is, of course, you can say
whether or not you're actually
using OpenGL ES 2.0.
Check that.
And make sure that you're
actually filtering
on OpenGL ES 2.0.
The second thing you can do--
this is sort of a bad option for
a lot of games if you're
only using DOLVIC.
But the vast majority of
performance-bound games are
actually using NDK.
So make sure to only build an
ARMv7-A binary and/or MIPS and
Intel binary.
Don't target ARMv5.
You'll eliminate a lot of
low-end devices that way.
All right, but now you're in
the issue of, I've got this
super, super, super
high-performance title that I
know can only target the
top 10% of devices.
Galaxy S3s, Galaxy S2s.
And if you're in that position,
there's nothing you
can do other than to go through
and eliminate those
devices based upon our
compatibility list.
IAN NI-LEWIS: And let's talk
a little bit about
why this is an issue.
Remember that Android isn't
unique in this.
I mean, in the desktop
space, this is
actually pretty normal.
But Android does have, actually,
a couple more GPU
vendors than what you'd find in
the general desktop space.
And we often get the question,
well, why don't we just
publish some statistics like,
what's the fill rate?
Well, there's some
problems there.
First off, everybody lies.
And those who aren't lying are
only not lying because they're
bad at something else.
So you can talk about fill rate
and you can talk about
polygon throughput.
You can talk about raw
vertex shader.
You can talk about
memory bandwidth.
But the truth is, on a GPU,
all of these things add up
into something that's even only
partially the picture.
Because not only do you have
different bandwidths and
different fill rates and
different arithmetic unit
designs, you also have
completely different
architectures, the main ones
being tiled or immediate mode.
DAN GALPIN: And there's
actually two things.
There's tiled deferred mode
and then there's tiled
immediate mode.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Which
is sort of a--
yeah.
DAN GALPIN: And so basically,
the question you have to ask
yourself is one, how
many devices--
IAN NI-LEWIS: Dude, you so
passed up an opportunity.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah?
IAN NI-LEWIS: The question you
have to ask yourself is, do
you feel lucky, punk?
DAN GALPIN: Exactly.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Well, do ya?
DAN GALPIN: So how many
devices do you
really want to hit?
Today, I think you're going to
want to hit a pretty large
cross-section of devices.
But you might be limited
because of memory.
You might be limited because
of just raw GPU power.
Today on Google Play, if you're
really limited by those
things-- and my advice to
everyone is try to target as
broad as possible.
If you're running a 3D game,
you're going to have a mipmap
with different versions of a
texture for things that are in
the distance, typically.
Take advantage of that and use
different mipmap levels.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Do you want
to use a MIP bias to--
OK, I can see that.
I will say, I don't think
there's anybody that's
terrible at vertex
performance.
So you want to have a certain
number of vertices, and you
can cut off this year's or
last year's devices.
I don't actually think there's
even been that
much progress in this.
But fill rate-wise, what's
the right thing to do?
Well, Dan's got a good idea.
If you're bound by input,
doing a MIP bias would
definitely reduce the amount of
memory the GPU is consuming.
It doesn't reduce the amount the
GPU is producing, which is
where you would reduce your
frame buffer size.
DAN GALPIN: So the second thing
you can do, and a lot of
developers don't do this, and I
think it's partially because
they don't know.
It's kind of hidden.
But one thing that you, as a
developer, can do if you're
using OpenGL, is you can
actually set the size of your
viewport in our windowing
system, so not even in OpenGL.
And we actually offer this sort
of hidden API which is
inside of Surface Holder
called Set Fixed Size.
And if you do that, it'll
actually automatically scale
your viewport up to the
size of your window.
So it's actually very,
very useful.
And that's done inside of
SurfaceFlinger, and it may
even be done with a
hardware composer.
So for a lot of reasons, we
definitely recommend doing
that, especially if your choices
are rendering to a
pixel buffer or actually
rendering to using this, you
should definitely use this.
You're going to get
more performance.
A lot of times when things are
really just heavily fill
limited, that's what
you should do.
Obviously, there's
shader effects.
There's other things
you can do.
But my general advice
on Android is, try
to make things scalable.
Try not to cut off users if you
absolutely can avoid it.
You want as many users as
possible to see your game.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Give yourself
some knobs so you can make
adjustments.
Don't necessarily expose
us to the users.
DAN GALPIN: Well, one of my
favorite games that does this
is Dead Trigger.
I mean, Dead Trigger
has a slider.
And with a lot of GPUs,
it'll [INAUDIBLE].
It'll say, you're guaranteed
to work at the
lowest quality only.
But you can slide it over, and
you can, say, turn on effects.
And you can see what happens.
And sometimes it may just
crash the game when you
actually try to run the game
with everything turned on.
But at least the user knows,
I turned on those effects.
It's crashing.
That's not good for
every developer.
Some developers are like, I
don't want users to ever see
my title crash.
I much prefer being given the
option of saying, let's try
turning it up and see
what happens.
And they do a whole bunch
of techniques--
they actually don't even use
resolution in that slider.
They're simply turning
off effects.
It's almost all turning
off, actually.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Well, remember
the things that
are going to be--
And texture quality.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Yeah, texture
fetches are
going to be a big deal.
On many GPs, especially
[INAUDIBLE]
Tyler's, state changes are
going to be a big deal.
On Ford renderers--
Tegra is the best example
of this--
your geometry sorting is
going to be a big deal.
DAN GALPIN: You want to take
advantage of early Z
rejection on Tegra.
It's absolutely critical.
The number of games we look at
that draw in the reverse order
and end up getting really slow
performance, people are like,
wow, this game is amazing
on Nexus 7.
They look at the next game,
they say, well,
this isn't very good.
And the reason why, often,
there's kind of two things--
design artwork, and also make
sure that they're doing draw
order that allows for early Z to
really take best advantage
of the hardware.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Now, remember
that all of the GPU
manufactures want games
to look great on
their particular chipset.
And they all have armies of
people that want to help games
look better on that chipset.
So if you're having specific
problems, contact Invidia,
contact Qualcomm, contact
imagination Technologies.
DAN GALPIN: Contact ARM.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Yeah,
contact ARM--
any of these.
And get some help because a
lot of times, it's just a
matter of rewriting a
shader or changing
your draw order around.
And don't forget, all of them
have really great tools for
investigating what your
draw calls are doing.
DAN GALPIN: I mean,
PerfHUD, the
Adreno Profiler, PVRTrace--
all of these tools are really,
really helpful.
And the best part for me, the
exciting part, is that a lot
of them now work on non-rooted
devices.
So even your consumer devices,
you can plug them right in.
PerfHUD works that way, Adreno
Profiler works that way.
PVRTune is slowly
getting there.
I mean, the thing with PVR is
that you'll run into weird,
goofy performance bugs with
PVR-- like, things that you
just don't expect because it
does all of these crazy
optimizations for you.
And you do one thing that trips
it up and says, oh crap,
I have to render
everything now.
And all of a sudden, your
performance cliffs.
IAN NI-LEWIS: I definitely
wouldn't limit that to PVR.
DAN GALPIN: No.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Everybody
does that.
DAN GALPIN: Everyone
But PVR, because it does so many
optimizations, you may be
shocked that one little
operation you do causes things
to suddenly slow down by
orders of magnitude.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Right.
Well, remember Wind-up Knight
and they fell over the
performance cliff--
DAN GALPIN: Exactly--
on ARM Mali.
That was the driver bug in
that particular case.
IAN NI-LEWIS: You never know
what's going to happen.
All of these are different.
DAN GALPIN: Absolutely.
Where large VBOs, which normally
help performance,
actually hurt them.
So yeah, absolutely.
IAN NI-LEWIS: So there are some
general best practices,
but if you really, really want
to push the envelope, then you
need to actually purchase some
of these units, talk to the
manufacturers, and tune
for each type of GPU.
But remember, there's
not that many.
There's the Tegra series,
the Adreno, the ARM
Mali, and the PVR.
There are a couple others,
but we don't--
DAN GALPIN: Yeah, those are
the ones that have volume.
Certainly, you also--
IAN NI-LEWIS: In terms
of gaming.
DAN GALPIN: In terms
of gaming volume.
I mean, certainly you can go and
grab Broadcom devices, the
Galaxy Y uses that.
You can grab a Raspberry Pie
if you want to play with a
Broadcom device.
And then there's also some
devices that are now using the
Marvell, which is the
Vivante Accelerator.
The new CoStar from
Vizio uses that.
So there are a few, but again,
the vast majority of your
phones and tablets that are
out there with the others.
IAN NI-LEWIS: We love all of our
devices here at Android,
but there are a few that
are made for gaming
and some that aren't.
So the top four you really
need to look at.
The others, it depends
on how broad you want
your audience to be.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah, absolutely.
And again, we're talking about
bleeding edge performance.
Ultimately, you might end up
being in a position where
you're actually going to
have to target the game
individually to different
devices.
We really like to avoid that.
My general guideline is do as
much as you can to try to make
sure the game is playable
in some form.
IAN NI-LEWIS: All right.
Well, we are coming
up on an hour now.
And I think we are
just about done.
And Engineer Dan wants to
get back to his life.
And we're out of beer.
DAN GALPIN: Oh crap.
IAN NI-LEWIS: So I guess we're
gonna call it a day.
Yes, it was great having
you with us.
Thanks very much
for tuning in.
We will be back next week.
We are playing with the format
of this show because we
started out as a review show.
We wanted to introduce
some games that
we hadn't seen before.
And now we kind of feel like
maybe we'd rather do a little
bit more engineering.
It's always been a
developer-focused show, and
we're thinking maybe we'd like
to do a deep dive on some
games that have performance
problems or design problems.
So let us know what
you'd like.
Of course, you can always
contact us on the Android
developers Google+ page.
Or if you want to send us a
personal message on G+ too, we
may actually see that.
You never know.
DAN GALPIN: Absolutely.
It happens.
IAN NI-LEWIS: And with that,
let's go ahead and have a
little Android play us out.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah, and definitely
continue to
nominate applications
[INAUDIBLE].
And you can even say, look, this
application would be just
awesome if it performed
better.
That's great.
We'll take a look at it.
We'll try to figure out why
is doesn't perform faster.
So again, let us know
what you want to do,
what you want to see.
This is your show.
IAN NI-LEWIS: No.
DAN GALPIN: It is.
IAN NI-LEWIS: It's kinda
your show now.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah, it is.
But there's a moderator page.
Continue to nominate things you
want to see on the show
and have a great weekend,
everyone.
IAN NI-LEWIS: That's right.
Come on, little Android.
Little Android.